The Wizarding World sport of quidditch
has made numerous appearances in the
Harry Potter video games over the years
from 2001's Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone on the PC to 2003
Standalone Quidditch game Harry Potter
Quidditch World Cup there was even a
Harry Potter mod for Minecraft that Mr
Beast yes that Mr Beast made a video on
all the way back in 2012. and this is a
mod from the movie Harry Potter and of
course there's a new Quidditch game on
the horizon with Harry Potter Quidditch
champions in this video we're going to
take a look at each game where quidditch
has appeared as a playable sport discuss
how developers have handled the gameplay
and talk about where things could
potentially go in the future it all
started with 2001's Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone which marked the
first time fans could play Quidditch in
a video game it happens within the
narrative and Loosely follows the events
of the book and movie as it happens in
both of those your first match is
against Slytherin there's a little intro
cut scene that plays and we even get
commentary from Lee Jordan
once you've reached this point in the
narrative you also unlock a new
quidditch league mode that's available
from the main menu in this mode if you
catch the snitch Gryffindor wins if you
are hit by too many bludgers though then
you'll faint and Gryffindor loses if you
can finish first or second in the league
you'll qualify for the finals against
Slytherin considering you're playing the
game as Harry and seeing the world
through his eyes you take on the role of
seeker and this is the only playable
position and that's true for both in the
main game as well as in the Quidditch
league as for the actual gameplay there
are a series of rings you fly through to
help you keep track of the golden snitch
the Rings actually aren't required
though as long as you stay close to your
target you'll have to watch out for the
occasional bludger though which can
knock you off course you can use shift
for a speed boost but the controls were
a bit wonky overall as your movement was
controlled by was and D on the keyboard
once you do get close enough to the
snitch and stay within range for a
moment a contextual menu appears at the
bottom of the screen with a little
snitch catching minigame all you need to
do is press the jump button when the
snitch goes inside the hand and it's
this basic formula set all the way back
in 2001 that For Better or Worse has
carried over into many future games
featuring quidditch it was even pretty
close to the same formula in the Game
Boy Advance version of Philosopher's
Stone here Oliver wood explains the
rules to Harry much like he does in the
movie but in the game the scene happens
immediately before his first match
against Slytherin you begin play only as
Harry and his role as the Seeker but
here it's from a top-down view you need
to stay within the snitches Halo and you
can press B to dodge incoming bludgers
after you stay within the halo for a
brief moment you'll have a chance to
actually catch the snitch here you need
to watch out for other players in the
bludgers all while you try and fly
through the Sparkles for a speed boost
as you progress through the Sparkles a
blue meter at the bottom begins to fill
once the meter is full a prompt that's
very similar to the PC game will appear
where you need to press either A or B to
grab the snitch again just wait for it
to go inside the hand quidditch was also
playable in the PlayStation version of
Harry Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
things are very similar here year with
more rings to fly through and again
commentary from Lee Jordan the menu that
appears at the bottom is slightly
different though but it's the same basic
premise and has another snitch grabbing
prompt to complete the game you'll get
to play games against both Hufflepuff
and Ravenclaw and if you manage to find
all 18 wizard cards during the game
you'll get to play a final match against
Slytherin and win the house Cup this
basic structure of quidditch that was
used in the first three games actually
carried over to Harry Potter in the
Chamber of Secrets on the PC in 2002
only playing as the Seeker commentary
from Lee Jordan and flying through a lot
of rings once again the console versions
for GameCube PS2 and Xbox used a very
similar system but with a completely
different engine graphic style and also
controller support which made flying
much more intuitive on the GBA version
the top down view was gone and replaced
by a more traditional third-person
camera behind the player the sparkling
Rings returned though as did the snitch
grabbing minigame at the end 2003
brought in a major New Era for video
game quidditch with the launch of Harry
Potter Quidditch World Cup this is again
game that many Potter fans even to this
day cite as one of the best games in the
series for the first time ever players
would get to play the sport from a more
team-focused lens rather than only
playing as the Seeker not only do you
get to play in the Hogwarts house cup
though you can also unlock the Quidditch
World Cup and play against the
International Teams from the series and
we can't forget the numerous
Collectibles that you can earn along the
way it all starts with Oliver wood and
Harry Potter who both give players a
brief overview of the sport and then you
get to choose one of the four houses
from there you'll go through a series of
challenges that teach you how to play
the game for the majority of each match
you'll be playing as the Chasers passing
the quaffle between them to try and
score goals you can also tackle the
opposing Chasers to try and steal the
quaffle as you score goals and complete
passes to teammates the snitch bar Atop
The Screen will begin to build once this
meter fills you'll take on the role of
seeker and attempt to catch the golden
snitch rather than flying through hoops
you'll have a horizontal gold band that
you have to try and stay between and
when you eventually get close enough to
this Niche you can immediately try to
catch it without out any additional
minigame appearing like in the source
material catching this Niche rewards
your team an extra 150 points and ends
the game after completing your first
game you'll learn how to take advantage
of your team's beaters which allow you
to hit bludgers at opponents you won't
take full control of the beaters though
instead you'll press a button to launch
the bludgers and guide them to your
target you also have special moves that
you can unlock and use during the game
to get a guaranteed goal against your
opponent or a guaranteed steal if you
use it defensively some of these team
special moves will actually score two
goals for you but the single scoring
Ones Will progress your snitch meter a
bit further the one position you don't
have any control over in quidditch World
Cup is the keeper overall the controls
work pretty well for the first ever
attempt at a dedicated Quidditch game
the most impressive part of the game
though was in all of the extra features
included such as 104 unlockable
quidditch cards and the fact that the
game wasn't limited to just the Hogwarts
teams once you win the Hogwarts house
cup you can compete in the Quidditch
World Cup as one of the International
Teams which includes Australia England
France Germany Japan the Nordic team
Spain and the USA and once you manage to
collect 65 of those quidditch cards
you'll unlock Victor Crum and the
Bulgarian team there are also different
stadiums and weather effects and even on
the house teams the developers included
names for the actual players from the
series such as Angelina Johnson Cho
Chang Roger Davies Cedric Diggory and
Draco Malfoy among others there were
certainly a level of care and attention
to detail put into this title that make
it clear why it's so beloved by fans
even to this day surprisingly British
World Cup even saw a release on the Game
Boy Advance alongside its console
counterpart in 2003 and while things
were modified to fit on the smaller
screen and to use fewer buttons many of
the overall mechanics are still present
here instead of the action taking place
from a third person perspective though
you'll see everything from a horizontal
view until it's time to catch the snitch
then you'll shift into a third person
view behind the Seeker the release of
quidditch World Cup though actually
seemed to have a negative effect in the
other Potter titles in fact they stopped
including quidditch entire early it did
not appear as playable at all in 2004's
Prisoner of Azkaban 2005's Goblet of
Fire or 2007's Order of the Phoenix
oddly enough though there was a playable
form of quidditch in the Order of the
Phoenix game on the Nintendo DS the
gameplay here was very similar to the
GBA version of quidditch World Cup where
he mostly play as the Chasers scoring
goals while the meter at the top slowly
builds toward the moment when you'll be
able to catch the snitch quidditch would
eventually make its return to the movie
based games in 2009 with Harry Potter
and the Half-Blood Prince you begin to
play as Harry in his role as Seeker but
you're still flying through Rings well
actually Stars this time the way you
catch the snitch though is quite a bit
different here it's all about the Rings
which change color as time passes they
start as green but will eventually turn
to yellow red and black before
disappearing completely if you missed
too many of the Stars you'll lose but
fly through enough of them and you'll
eventually catch the snitch no snitch
grabbing minigame this time the whole
thing feels even a little bit more on
Rails than the other games and almost
like an interactive cut scene rather
than actually quidditch now we can't
forget about the mobile titles because
quidditch has been featured in both
Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery and Harry
Potter magic awakened in Hogwarts
mystery the actual quidditch gameplay is
mostly a rhythm timing minigame as for
magic awaken it's not currently
available in the global launch of the
game but it did appear during the game's
soft launch matches were only 3v3 with
everyone playing as a chaser you
actually fly in a first person view and
tap left or right to stay on course now
if you bump into other players You're
Gonna Lose stamina points eventually
you'll build up enough to take a shot at
one of the Hoops with the quaffle and
you just tap on a ring to throw it
through as for all of these Harry Potter
games that you see on screen now they
did not include playable quidditch with
no quidditch in Hogwarts Legacy but a
dedicated Quidditch game on the horizon
in Harry Potter Quidditch Champions it
seems as the future of the Wizarding
sport in video games will be defined by
the Standalone title rather than as an
add-on Mini-Game and other Potter titles
that being said quidditch remains one of
the most popular fan requests for a
Hogwarts Legacy DLC or potential sequel
it's interesting to note how most
developers have landed on a similar
gameplay Loop and it's also fair to
question where quidditch Champions and
other future titles could take the
iconic Wizarding World sport for
starters there are inherent issues as
it's written in the books and how the
Canon point system translates into video
games even though Seeker is the position
that's been featured most in the games
it's proven difficult to find that
bright competitive balance while also
keeping the game fun the act of catching
the snitch needs to be challenging
enough to prevent games from ending
quickly but not so hard that games go on
for too long so far developers have
struggled to figure out a way to manage
this that doesn't involve flying through
Rings it's also important to find ways
that keep each position feeling part of
the larger team for a sport where the
positions can often feel quite
disconnected if you're curious to see
how I think these issues could be
handled in the upcoming Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions then check out the
video on the right side of your screen
now where I break that down in even
greater detail as always witches and
wizards thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon